tell me if this sounds familiar a man
walks into a store he searches for a
certain section of books he takes out a
can of lighter fluid I know why he
burned the books why because he wrote
Sydney Hall one of the best writers of
our time I've been searching for him for
years
refuse no fish man sitting is one of our
brightest students it was brilliant
what if I wrote enough what would it be
about it's your name melody no no no me
why do you keep running away from me
because it's fun
[Music]
you've been number one on the bestseller
list for eight months I'm seeing face
things that aren't there really one
right so it's gonna shake people up you
should get off be sure to take me with
you she write about me you know my
father is this is me I should write a
book about him you'll be singing a
different tune tomorrow what happens
tomorrow this book is a dangerous sign
of the times the book burnings I
apologize for nothing
being full I don't know what he wants he
knows everything about me
no one is claimed to see or hear from
Sydney Hong over five years now how is
that possible
everywhere I go he's with me you were
the last people to see him alive that's
not a beginning to a great book I don't
know what is
the entire course of a person's life can
change a millisecond
this has to end Sydney
business person isomer you think
give me the information about Sydney
Hall and you'll never see me again
you
you